the show has become such a massive hit
I'm curious to know Luke how does this
compare to your 902 Ando days 902 I know
was bigger this way you know
Riverdale burns white-hot I mean you
know I know - it kind of scorched the
earth in all directions but this thing
burns hot touch through stuff it's the
social media it's the kids it's the the
fan frenzy that goes with it it's Twyla
et sat down with Luke Perry and his
Riverdale co-star KJ app' in NYC where
the former Beverly Hills 90210 star
fondly recalled his perfectly quaffed
90s do insane it's insane now his TV son
tells ET he's just trying to keep up one
of my favorite things is that Luke when
you were in nano - no your hair was
iconic and it still looks great it was
much taller than yours bro you compared
hair tips of course yeah yeah KJ also
reveals that he ditched his character
Archie Andrews signature red locks to
play a younger version of his on-screen
dad for an upcoming throwback episode
but I had to do his hair I'd have his
hair was as close as I could in the
throwback episode which was pretty cool
yes like that but they needed it a
little higher as well like you see did
you get to have your natural hair color
is there ever a world when Archie
doesn't have to have his signature red
hair um well there is when for the
throwback you were so for sure they dyed
it every day not only well fans get to
see KJ without those ginger locks
they'll also get to see the hunky star
without his shirt a lot okay Jay this is
the most shirtless we've ever seen you
on the show right this season
yeah was I should listen that person who
said I was that oh yeah you're getting
you a little tattoo episode two and
you're like playing on the field you've
really stepped up your gym game and
we're not complaining oh really
you tell it mm-hmm yeah no I've been
going hard for sure I told you guys this
season is gonna be a game-changer
I've probably been shirtless if we're
shooting 308 this is the first episode I
haven't been show us and mind you I I
buy him clothes the kid has shirts to
wear and I get shorter and shorter
everyday they do I'm not good at laundry
they keep shrinking up and they're
really tight and while the 21 year old
portrays a younger Perry in season 3
Mark Consuelos his son Michael joined
the cast to play a younger version of
his character
Hyrum Lodge KJ what was it like acting
opposite of him
that kid looks so much like his dad and
sounds so much like his dad there were
so many times where I thought I was that
he was on set but I looked over and it
was Michael yeah he's a killer he was
great
[Applause]
[Music]